today the european commission has
adopted the 39th annual report on trade
defense instruments in 2020
it shows that the system for protecting
eu businesses against unfair trade
practices remained effective in 2020
despite the practical challenges
presented by the kovit-19 pandemic
in particular the commission
first continue the high level of eu
trade defense activity by swiftly
introducing temporary changes to its
work practices
by the end of 2020 the eu had in place
150 trade defense measures
10 more than at the end of 2019.
second strengthens its actions against
subsidies from third countries
in particular we completed two
anti-subsidy investigations that for the
first time
imposed court of valid duties on
cross-border financial support
third continue to support eu exporters
facing trade defense investigations in
export markets
at the end of 2020 there were 178 trade
defense measures in force affecting uh
exports which is five more than in 2019
and represents the highest number so far
in the commission's monitoring activity
and fourth given the central role of
enforcement of trade defense measures in
the bond alliance commission agenda we
improved the enforcement and monitoring
system
this is part of the european european
commission's new trade strategy whereby
the eu took a more assertive stance in
defending its interest against unfair
trade practices for further news you can
check our daily news
thank you very much miriam don't just
read the daily news read the actual
report i'm sure you will find lots of
interesting data there
for
your articles and media pieces so
finally a technical point
for all of you
we had some
difficulties in the past months you may
remember
with the
famous elisto de puente preview
which is such a useful tool for you i
had many comments on your part
we've finally been able to
solve the issue and
on the screen behind me
you will see that if you now go to the
commission's web page register of
commission documents
which you can easily find through your
search engine you will see on the right
hand menu a button that takes you
directly to the list of preview the list
of tentative agenda items for
upcoming college meetings
we know that this item
is extremely useful to you so we were
attained to find
a solution i would like nevertheless to
remind you that the lpp as it is known
is only an indicative list for planning
purposes
the actual agenda of the college is set
by the
weekly meetings of heads of cabinet
the week of the college meeting itself
and as you know planning is only
planning things can change for a whole
series of reasons so please always be
careful when using this list
right that's it in terms of our formal
announcements
opportunity
phillip
philip your mic somebody ah sorry can
you start again please we missed the
beginning
go ahead
can you hear me
yeah absolutely go ahead
thank you so i have to come back to a
question i raised last week in the
midday because it wasn't clarified
neither then or in the bilateral
follow-up
it's on the humanitarian aid for afghans
which the commission president announced
last week she said on
she tweeted on tuesday
it was uh to be quadrupled nearly
quadrupled to over 200 million
but
an over a breakdown which was sent to
one of my colleagues says it's only
126 million and the
other 79 million are for longer term
development so i can't
see how this fits together
no i think what we have said has
clarified the issue we are talking about
humanitarian assistance
and the difference is that uh some of
the amount
goes directly to the to afghanistan to
support people in afghanistan and the
rest goes to countries in
in the region but balash perhaps you
want to add a word on this
indeed so i don't have much update
compared to what i said on friday on the
podium um all the fresh money that we
are talking about is going to be going
for uh humilitarian purposes
all the money
will be going through
our humanitarian partner organizations
be it ngos or international
organizations notably
the un
the money has been made available in
order to respond to the incredibly
high amount of humanitarian aid needs
underground and
we're looking at not only afghanistan
but also the neighboring countries
especially those that will be
receiving an influx of refugees
from afghanistan so i repeat again
the whole amount is going to be
provided for
humanitarian purposes
so that we
stand
with the afghan people
especially
those that will have to
flee the country or remain in the
country and continue to live in in
difficult circumstances
thank you balash philip you have a
follow-up
because it's so explicit in in the
breakdown which uh
was provided by the commissioner it is
not a leak it says president fonda line
announced yesterday in the context of g7
euro 205 million funding for afghanistan
which partly concerns humanitarian aid
and it also says
the commission
document
79 million allocated funds for longer
term development so this is not
humanitarian aid and it is very explicit
is this the wrong breakdown
what is
look phillip i can only reiterate what
i've said we move from a bit above 50
million euros 57 million which was
allocated for humanitarian aid for
afghanistan
before the the crisis or the events that
we now know
unfolded and the amount was
increased partially through a direct
increase of the echo budget partially
through other actions which target
other countries in the region all of
this is meant for humanitarian aid now
perhaps you are focusing on the
technical description of the um of the
aid as such but the objective of the age
of the aid sorry is to support the
humanitarian needs of afghans following
the
events in afghanistan these past weeks
all right
we will
now stay on
afghanistan related questions so please
only only keep your hand raised sorry if
your question
is on afghanistan
yes
thank you eric hello yes i have also a
question about afghanistan and aid to
afghanistan refugees and migrants
as far as i know there will be um
interior ministers or home affairs
council meeting tomorrow in brussels
and
i would like to ask if we can expect
that
the meeting will discuss
what
the commission president said would be
the pledging by member states to
provide the places or in time with us
to afghanistan migrants
refugees
and link to that question is also the
situation
along the belarus and polish border i
wrote about it myself last week and i
think we discussed that
the press conference and as you know
the european court of human rights had
issued the
ruling on interim measures to help to
provide the humanitarian aid water food
the medical aides but also to more than
30 afghan
refugees have been stranded
between the borders within in the broad
area because the police authorities
don't allow them to enter
their territory and to apply for asylum
so
i wonder if that has changed by now
because we can expect i think secretary
called human rights will also look at
this issue about the right to asylum uh
later on in september thank you
thank you moses if you don't mind we
will focus uh on your question related
to afghanistan
first see if there are other questions
related to this and then we will come
back to the issue
of the situation at the border between
belarus and poland so in afghanistan the
council tomorrow
that's
hello so first of all we i can indeed
confirm that there would be a meeting
tomorrow of the justice uh of the home
affairs ministers uh dedicated to the
situation in afghanistan we published a
daily news item uh on this today
mentioning the commission's um
participation in that by vice president
hinas and commissioner johansson who
will be back from the us uh the the
meeting will discuss all the different
aspects of
um the
the situation in afghanistan and the
eu's response as a regards the portfolio
of the home affairs ministers and
perhaps if you need an overview of all
the different aspects of that i could
refer you to the statement that
commissioner johansson made at the
ipcr
meeting on ministerial level on the 18th
of august which we published and which
contains a
a good explanation of how the commission
views the situation and what are the
different aspects to be considered
thank you
i see other questions on afghanistan and
on aid so let's go back to that oliver
hello thank you for this
you said a part of the aid
eu provides would go to organizations in
afghanistan
uh
are you even aware which organizations
are still active there given you know
the
the
the rise to power of the taliban and how
do you avoid that this money somehow is
funneled towards the taliban regime that
it basically aids them to provide you
know public
goods to the afghans which they couldn't
themselves so how do you what that this
money ends up in the hands of the
taliban and actually a breakdown of all
the ua to afghanistan would be helpful
if you have a link or something you
could send it to us it would be very
good thank you
thank you oliver welcome back i'll give
the floor again to banash
on questions that we discussed last week
already so
let me start with the second question
i have a global figure for you starting
from 1994. uh we've provided one billion
euro for afghanistan in humanitarian aid
and this year until now we are at 57 so
the 57 million came uh before the
taliban taliban takeover and by the way
this contains already a top-up in july
when we reacted to a a significant
drought plaguing the country
now um
your questions about our humanitarian
partners in the country so in general as
you know we work with ngos
and international organizations notably
the u.n these are the partners which
implement our
humanitarian aid on the ground i'm not
able to be more specific than this at
the moment i will i will check and and i
will see if i can come up with a
specific list of partners we have inside
the country now i get a very similar
question last week on how we make sure
that the money
the funds end up in the right hands
um of course we have extremely uh um we
have a contractual relationship with the
uh humanitarian partners organizations
concerned this is a very robust
relationship contains a wide range of
requirements
there are reporting requirements so we
keep a very close eye on on
how the money is actually used on the
underground and in general
this
works very well
you asked me about uh the presence of
our partners in the country
another question we discussed last week
obviously this is a highly evolving
situation uh that needs to be monitored
on an on a daily basis but what we've
seen until now is that
our partner organizations are committed
to staying in afghanistan therefore
as long as as long as they
are there and they continue to
carry out the operations
that they have we will stand with them
and ultimately will stand with the
afghan people
oliver you have a follow-up
yes thank you
you referred to the
very robust contractual relationship
with the um eight organizations that
i mean the situation on the ground
look there's an eight organization
that's a very tight contract with you
but then there's a bunch of bearded guys
with machine guns walking into their
office and saying actually the bags of
wheat and rice you got financed through
the eu now they're gonna be now
distributed to the through the whatever
local taliban
relief council or something you simply
cannot prevent this from happening and i
think this is the concern many people
have that when the eu increases its aid
on the ground it might actually help
bolster and strengthen the taliban
regime so is this is this
is this a risk that you are that you are
reckoning with uh that basically the
taliban don't really care about whether
unicef or whoever has a relationship
with you that is on paper very solid but
they simply you know force them to hand
over any any any aids materials and
goods they have and food thank you
oliver um
i think you need to remember that
wherever humanitarian aid
is required across the globe
but more particularly in conflict areas
this is a risk that exists
um and um therefore if we only limited
our interventions in terms of
humanitarian aid to safe regions uh
basically
we would not uh we would not actually be
providing aid to people in need what the
president has said very very clearly is
that we would strive to continue
supporting ngos that are helping afghans
as long as the conditions on the ground
allow it
and therefore obviously if um the sort
of event that you described in your
question arrive
arise sorry we will reassess the
situation but for the moment the
intention
is to continue
supporting the afghans who are suffering
from the conflict through humanitarian
aid as we do in other conflict areas and
across across the globe so i think
that's where we stand today we will have
to see how how things pan out in
in reality on the ground in the coming
days and weeks
nawab
this humanitarian aid is already being
delivered or are you going to start
delivering it thank you
yeah so the 57 million that i was
referring to is already um sort of
contracted now as as for the additional
additional amount uh well at the moment
as i said last week we are working on a
on a breakdown which needs uh which
needs uh which requires a bit of time
and then there are no hurdles in the way
we will be
deploying we will be deploying the aid
as soon as possible given the extremely
dire humanitarian needs underground
thank you very much other questions on
afghanistan
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
peter
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
afghanistan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we
see uh thank you mariaroni from athens
news agency and opentv
um i have a question regarding
tomorrow's meeting of home affairs
minister i would like to ask if the
european commission is going to set a
specific target
on resettlements from afghanistan
thank you
thank you for albert
thank you so the the question of
resettlement will be discussed in
general but um to my knowledge we
i do not have any announcement to make
about a specific target of for
resettlement from um afghanistan the um
when it comes to resettlement for
2022 in general the commission um
in intends to would intend to allocate a
budget of about 300 million
euro to that to that effort which would
correspond to about 30 000 resettlement
places in general
that's i think as much as i can say
about this issue at this point
thank you
i see that there was a question in the
chat which i had not seen
peter that would be for you again
perhaps you had seen it from rice from
the washington post let me read out the
question
russia is calling for the international
community to unfreeze afghanistan's
assets and convene a conference on
afghanistan's recovery is this something
the eu would
consider
well thank you there are complex
discussions on going about what to do
next when it comes to afghanistan
handling it politically from the
security point of view from the
migration point of view and also from
development assistance point of view and
humanitarian assistance point of view
currently there is the decision by the
eu
institutions that our development
programs are suspended frozen until we
see how the situation develops and until
we have assurances that the necessary
conditionalities will be
met
i can also recall that uh currently
there are number of
members of taliban under existing eu
sanctions these eu sanctions are
basically the alignment with the united
nations security sanctions so unless
there is a decision to change this
then you will stick to the current
positions and we will not change the
current position as long as we don't see
any uh reliable incredible guarantees
about the behavior of taliban in running
afghanistan
with respect to the international
obligations afghanistan governments have
undertook over the last years with the
respect to the
fundamental rights and freedoms human
rights specifically rights of women and
minorities so the discussions about how
to handle all these related issues
including uh financial assistance or
possible unfreezing or further freezing
are ongoing and from the eu point of
view will be judged based on the
criteria i just mentioned
again this will be one of the topics
discussed thoroughly by the foreign
ministers during their informal meeting
later this week in slovenia
thank you very much
okay
um this closes our chapter on
afghanistan so i will call
my friend albert once again to the
podium now to answer the question
related to the situation at the border
between belarus
and poland that moses had asked
initially
thank you and also for the opportunity
to do a little bit of exercise in our
complicated office days
so regarding
regarding that that particular difficult
situation maybe
uh i i think it's it's really important
to emphasize that a a very significant
part of the difficulty of that situation
is how it was created the fact that it
is um an attempt by a third country to
instrumentalize people for political
purposes which is something that we very
firmly
very firmly reject and have described as
uh as a form of aggression um
now when it comes to the specific
legal question on um the order of the
european court of human rights uh the
the commission doesn't comment on uh
judgments or orders of uh the european
court of human rights even though we
follow very closely uh the the
jurisprudence of uh the court poland is
of course a signatory to
the european convention of human rights
and therefore uh has uh committed to
implementing the judgments and orders of
the european court of human rights and
from our side we remain in very close
contact with the polish authorities to
make sure that uh this very difficult
situation is managed uh in in full
compliance with um
uh all the all the relevant obligations
and in in the appropriate way uh taking
into account the
the way also in which it was created
thank you very much are there other
questions for adelberg on this issue
gabriela is your question on this
in any case you have the floor since
you're the only one with the hand raised
for the moment go ahead
thank you very much it's not about this
case but about the czech republic i
wanted to ask you a comment the
local media and the czech republic today
quote a letter from dg reggio and to the
government saying some of czech
republic's um eu funding may be at stake
because of the conflict of interest
um with prime minister rubbish's company
agro
tour i think it's called
so i wanted to ask if you could confirm
the contents of the letter and and give
us any more detail thank you
thank you very much
i turn to balash
on this
yes indeed so i will give you a brief uh
answer first and then let's see if we
will need clarification so in order to
address a horizontal risk related to the
interpretation and application of a
provision in the czech conflict of
interest act relating to beneficiary
companies held within trust funds
it was identified during a commission
that was identified during a commission
audit in 2019 the commission has issued
a warning of interruption
letter advising the national authorities
for all the erdf and esf programs in
czechia that
they will interrupt any future payment
any future payment claims in respect of
such companies pending the
implementation of systemic improvements
to address the risk
right
i wanted to check perhaps with vivian
if vivian had something to say nope okay
all right very good
any other questions on this
follow-up
detail in the case of the czech republic
how much funding is at stake does it um
relate to past funding that would have
to be repaid by the czech republic or is
it about future payments
and if so how much was sort of um you
know earmarked that won't be delivered
now before czech republic solves the
structural horizontal risk thank you
so i will switch to more human language
now so the context here is the audit
report
that
the commission has carried out in the
recent past in that report we looked
into a hundred
operations and we as you may remember
from our earlier discussion we
established that there was no need to
recover
funds for the simple reason that the
czech authorities did not declare any
expenses for
the operations concern so here what we
are actually seeing in this letter is
that
as long as there are systemic
improvements uh carried out uh in in um
czechia and as long as essentially the
all the recommendations formulated in
the in the audit report are not uh
carried out we are advising the czech
authorities not to declare expenses that
are due
for
companies whose beneficial owners are
trust funds that's what we are saying so
it's it's a warning it's not about
recovering
any funds at this point there is no need
for that we are simply advising them not
to declare expenses for operations which
which involve such companies
gary you have another follow-up
yes thank you sorry just trying to
understand so what you're saying is that
as long as czech republic doesn't
implement these recommendations
and the trust the
trust funds or companies owned
indirectly by prime minister bambish
will not get any funding any future
funding from erdf and esf is that
correct
so what's correct is that we expect the
czech authorities to implement all the
recommendations that were put forward
in in the audit report in order to
especially clarify the situation of
companies which are held
by trust funds and as long as this is
not the case we advise the czech
authorities not to send not to declare
expenses
for operations involving companies whose
beneficial owners at restaurants
i think that's very clear okay
thank you very
much i see no further questions on this
so yes i've seen you don't worry uh
thank you balash please go ahead
hold on hold on hold on you need to wait
until your mic is red before you start
asking the question okay thank you maeve
mcmahon your news thank you for the
floor i have a covert related question
on the european commission's
recommendations to reintroduce eu travel
restrictions on the us i read could you
let me know if this is true and what
more you can tell me and also what other
countries could be removed from this
safe list thank you so much
thank you very much adelberg is going to
do a bit more exercise
he doesn't need to go to the gym
anymore well he didn't need to any case
go ahead
there we go
thank you very much um so when
maybe i can start uh with specifying
that it is not about a european
commission's recommendation but it's a
council recommendation that uh that
creates the um
that regulates the travel restriction at
uh at the eu
concerning inbound travel to the eu in
the context of the pandemic and
accordingly um i would invite you to uh
ask this question to uh our colleagues
in the in the council presidency or in
the council secretariat who will be able
to advise you better about the the
procedure um i can perhaps only only
mention that the the the question of uh
travel between the eu and the us so both
when it comes to
eu us travelers coming to the eu and uh
travelers from the eu going to the us is
something that uh of course we follow
extremely closely and in fact we are
also discussing with our u.s
counterparts you may know that
commissioner for home affairs
commissioner is in the us
um
has been in the us for the last few days
and in fact it's also an issue that she
raised with her counterpart secretary
mayorkas
when it comes to the
the travel from the eu to to the us so
it's it's something that we we follow of
course very closely
all right any other questions for
adelberg on this issue of travel
restrictions remo
i'm not sure it's for albertan i'm
asking anyways um
[Music]
okay but
before you see if i give you the floor
then i'm not sure neither if it's also a
council recommendation or is it
something for the commission but
um since there are some several
countries in the european union that are
red or even dark red
would the commission um
be in favor to reun introduce also some
travel restrictions and for
insane intra-eu travel like current time
maybe it's for christian i don't know
yes but i think our physician on this
has always been abundantly clear and we
have actually a uh
we have a regulation that introduces the
eu uh digital covid certificate that
specifies very clearly what uh what our
position is on the uh on the issue and
therefore nothing has changed from that
perspective uh even if certain
indicators are changing it's then for
member states um to see
whether in view of changing
circumstances they may consider that
specific measures
are required but we have
we have a regulation in place for the eu
dcc that says that if you are
a holder of a certificate that shows
that you are either fully vaccinated
that you have done a test or that you
have recovered from kovid that you
should be able to travel
you should be able to travel through
through the through the eu with of
course always safeguards for member
states if they consider that this is the
case but this is then from member states
to the side
okay we're jumping back and forth
between subjects i'm going to have to
ask you to help us manage
the the midday so that we do topic
after topic which helps colleagues who
then consult the uh the midday recording
afterwards
any other questions for adelberg on
home affairs
that is not the case
so
um i go to derek
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
it's not for for a little bit
today uh in poland um
commissioner europa vice president
europe i will meet with the polish prime
minister matthew so
what will be the topic of the discussion
and what is the what will be the message
of vice president to the to the polish
authorities thank you very much
thank you lukash christian
yes uh
thank you lukas for the question
um
what i can see on this is that i mean
vice president yurova was
invited by the city of dansk for the
events to commemorate the 41st
anniversary of the solidarity
declaration and the 82nd
anniversary of the outbreak of the
second world war
this is with the main
purpose of the visit uh the vice
president has uh however taken or is
taking the occasion uh to meet also
other important uh interlocutors
uh in poland including uh of course the
the prime minister which she will meet
later today
i don't have much to say in advance on
the content it will be about of course
issues of common interests pertaining to
the portfolio of the vice president
but we're of course happy to provide
with a readout afterwards
thank you very much are there other
questions for christian on rule of law
issues
that is not the case
any other questions for us today
no so thank you very much and see you
tomorrow